what would happen if you poured liquid
nitrogen all over your car or use it to
fight a fire or even tried to cool down
with it on a hot day
liquid nitrogen may look like a lot of
fun when you're watching people dump
everyday objects into it but it's
actually a very dangerous substance and
if someone were to dump you in it the
fun would quickly come to an end this is
what F and here's what would happen if
you fell into a pool of liquid nitrogen
did you know that hundreds of people
fallin Tara Lee jumped into a pool of
liquid nitrogen it's true it happened at
a promotional pool party in 2013 by the
end of the event one person was in a
coma and eight others had been rushed to
the hospital so what is it that makes
this substance so dangerous what would
you feel as you Dovan to a pool full of
it
and would it actually be strong enough
to freeze your entire body before we go
jumping into a whole pool of it let's
get to know liquid nitrogen a little
better liquid nitrogen or ln2 as the
cool kids call it is non-flammable
odorless and colorless and it creates a
notorious fog whenever it's exposed to
room temperature air it can be used to
freeze and transport food products to
preserve sperm and eggs and to remove
skin abnormalities among other things
recently its use has been embraced by
the public with chefs and bartenders
using it to create fancy ice creams and
cocktails with this new fascination with
liquid nitrogen and the fact that it's
available to the public something
terrible was bound to happen and that
brings us back to the ln2 pool party
that we mentioned before in an effort to
create a smoke effect to impress guests
a resort in Mexico poured four large
cans of liquid nitrogen into the hotel
pool it created an impressive fog but it
also did something the organisers didn't
know about it displaced the oxygen
around the pool
and with no oxygen guests couldn't
breathe luckily though since it was just
four cans of liquid nitrogen that were
added slowly it boiled off in the water
before it made contact with anyone's
skin so how much worse would it have
been if the entire pool was filled with
pure liquid nitrogen well one thing's
for sure you wouldn't want to go for a
swim in it you'd be better off just
dipping your hand in quickly if you were
to quickly submerge your hand in liquid
nitrogen it would feel frozen but there
wouldn't be any frostbite or damage
because of something called the
Leidenfrost effect because liquid
nitrogen boils at the very low
temperature of minus 196 degrees Celsius
it will beat up and create a layer of
vapor underneath it when it touches any
surface that's at room temperature
similar to when you drop water onto a
flat heated surface so if you dipped
your hand inside liquid nitrogen a vapor
barrier would immediately form that
protected your hand from freezing but
the protective barrier would only be
temporary if you are planning on taking
a long swim and you wouldn't be coming
back out instead you'd get severe
frostbite all over your body then the
cold would work its way deeper inside
you muscles fat your blood and every
other liquid in your body would be
frozen solid if you kept your head above
the surface your body would freeze
underneath you and you'd sink right down
but hey on the bright side there
probably wouldn't be much pain involved
since the nerve damage would be so
severe and occurs so quickly as terrible
as this would be for a living creature
it could actually be beneficial for a
dead one instead of being buried or
cremated
some people have chosen to have their
bodies frozen when they die it's called
cryogenic freezing and the idea is you
can be frozen and brought back to life
at a later date but that's a topic for
another what-if
[Music]